[Aplausos]
o pessoal também
quem aqui romper uma relação de amizade
ou saiu do grupo de rock rap da família
ou dos amigos antigos nas últimas
eleições levanta a mão por favor
o qual esperava muita gente mas não
tanta
o assunto do papo hoje é esse como o que
a gente pode ter mais e melhores
conversas com quem pensa muito diferente
de nós
qual é o preço que a gente está pagando
por não ter essas conversas com os
nossos pais
as nossas mães nossos filhos nossos
amigos esposos e esposas dos chefes ao
preço que a gente paga
eu sei o peso que eu já paguei já pedi
relação com pessoas que eu amava
já perdi amizade já perdi sociedade por
não conseguir fazer isso nos últimos dez
anos o meu trabalho desenvolvido ter
conversas regulares com pessoas que
pensam muito diferente de mim
nos últimos dois em especial tem sido
chamado para conduzir a roda de conversa
com quem nem queria tá nessa roda de
conversa
muitas vezes foi obrigado a tauá o tema
central dessas rodas têm sido machismo
público principal homens ou seja não é
um papo fácil eu vou em chão de fábrica
eu vou empresa eu vou à escola conversa
com juízes com juízes com homens e
mulheres de todas as idades e muitas
vezes a recepção inicial que eu tenho é
essa a avisou não quer me ver mas ela tá
lá então como é que eu faço para criar
uma conexão nesse tipo de contexto
isso não é simples quero compartilhar um
pouco do que aprendi nesses dez anos
em breves minutos para que vocês não
precisem cometer os erros que já cometi
eu acabei de liderar um estudo que
escutou mais de 9 mil pessoas para
entender como é que elas se sentem
quando elas conversam com alguém que
pensa muito diferente
o tema específico do estudo eram
conversas com temas de gênero mas a
minha experiência diz que se aplica a
outras coisas o que a gente viu a gente
viu três grandes grupos na sociedade
brasileira
primeiro tem as pessoas construtores de
pontes que é quem ativamente vai
conversar com quem pensa muito diferente
delas quem ativamente lê notícias com
pontos de vista opostos
quem tem mais curiosidade mas paciência
depois tem o grupo das pessoas em
trânsito 50 por cento da população é que
estão um pouco lá um pouco caótica mas
fechado era mais aberto tem um pouco de
paciência mas não tanta
e depois tem o grupo das pessoas entre
muros quem é que que são as pessoas que
não fazem questão nenhuma dessas
conversas
as pessoas que evitam lê notícia com um
ponto de vista oposto ao seu
pessoas com baixa curiosidade e com
baixa paciência era onde eu estava eu
sou uma pessoa que já arremessou e
quebrou celulares já que a proposta já
quebrou objetos em casa e já quebrei
minha própria mão com um soco na parede
em conversas com as quais eu não
conseguir lidar
então não era o melhor exemplo de
equilíbrio emocional nem de habilidade
em construir pontes
mas eu quero mostrar que é possível
mudar a gente viu no nosso estudo que
sete em cada dez pessoas acreditam que
vale a pena conversar com quem pensa
muito diferente de você
entretanto só duas em cada dez pessoas
ativamente está buscando ter essas
conversas na prática então a gente acha
que é bom mas não faz
quais são os obstáculos a gente mapeou
isso número 1 agressividade
depois radicalismo do outro falta de
energia
falta de empatia do outro depois
argumentos ruins então a gente vê que
parece ser muito mais uma questão
emocional do que uma questão racional
só 8% das pessoas diz que falta empatia
nelas
então o problema há sempre no outro né
assim para o outro que não está
conseguindo nunca gente a gente viu
também a grande maioria de nós
convivi com quem pensa muito diferente
mas a gente escolhe não se aproximar a
gente escolhe não fazer isso toda
agressão séria expressão trágica de uma
necessidade emocional não atendida
essa é uma fase maravilhosa do macho
rosenberg um psicólogo que o dinheiro
então quais são as necessidades
emocionais de vocês que não estão sendo
atendidas e das outras pessoas indo além
do nosso estudo
a gente viu que quando a gente dialoga
com alguém que pensa parecido com a
gente
ele sente curiosidade animação alegria
mas quando a conversa com quem pensa
muito diferente
cansaço agressividade frustração falta
de paciência
então a gente consegue entender qual é o
tamanho do muro ele tem que ser capazes
de roubar porque esse muro tem
agressividade cansaço falta de paciência
falta de energia como a gente supera
isso não é contestado na internet
pessoal não é só falando sobre empatia
não é discutindo isso o tempo inteiro é
praticando empatia não basta a gente tem
que treinar então vou abrir aqui o que
eu tenho chamado de caixa de ferramentas
das pessoas construtoras de pontes
essa caixinha começa com o seguinte
motivação a gente não entra nesses
diálogos com motivação estreita de
querer convencer o ganhar se eu quero
dominar humilhar ou ridicularizar o
outro a pessoa vai sentir isso
o que eu sugiro entrar com motivação
mais ampla de querendo ter uma conexão
humana com outra pessoa para aprender
eu quero escutar
chega ser violento acha que alguém vai
pensar como eu depois de 15 minutos a
pessoa tem 20 30 40 anos de história de
vida e agora eu quero dizer para ela em
cinco minutos que é errada e que eu sou
correto
como é que a gente pode ampliar nossa
motivação
esse é o ponto zero em seguida
equilíbrio emocional
aprendi isso a duras penas na quebrando
muita coisa antes de ver que eu tinha
que ir ao chão interno
eu precisava de uma base aqui
segundo a organização mundial de saúde
vinte e nove por cento das pessoas em
são paulo tem um problema mental ou seja
um terço dessa platéia não está nada bem
rio quem não deve estar bem então quando
a gente tem esses diálogos pessoal faz
sentido a gente cuidar de si e cuidar do
outro quando eu não tenho um chão
interno
qualquer coisinha que o outro disse
virou frança me derruba aí eu vou sair
da conversa ou querer devolver a ofensa
com algo mais cruel violento ainda no
meu caso eu venho desenvolvendo e se
conectar da prática de meditação e
silêncio aprendendo com professores e
professoras dentro de tradições e
linhagens fazendo isso junto com uma
rede de outros praticantes
isso é o que tem funcionado para mim
como que vocês vão cultivar um espaço de
equilíbrio interno porque esses dois
pontos pessoal são a chave de tudo eu
vou até falar de técnica e mais
ferramentas etc
mas a gente não tem essa base tudo vira
uma coisa mais mecânica mais falsa
então isso é a chave aqui dentro não as
ferramentas por mais que eu fale delas
o terceiro ponto vai ter essa conversa
vai no olho a olho nu não é conversa de
what's up
não há conversa ddm não é conversa de
facebook com vida e senta cara a cara e
uma vez que você está sentado cara a
cara faça perguntas claras
escute a pessoa
interrompeu ela quem está achando isso
daqui é óbvio o bobo é porque não está
praticando isso porque quando a gente
começa a fazer isso com regularidade a
gente vê o quão difícil é estar de
frente pra alguém que não pensa como a
gente fazer uma pergunta escutá lo a
dizer tudo o que ela pensa em
interromper
eu gosto de fazer perguntas bem simples
então essa pessoa me dizem já aconteceu
várias vezes os homens são melhores
líderes econômicos e políticos mesmo
porque eles são mais racionais
eles são mais competentes mais
comprometidos
eu digo sim por que exatamente você
pensa assim e não te perguntando com
ironia nem com raiva nem com
agressividade o curioso essa é a postura
curiosidade
às vezes a pessoa nunca teve a chance de
desenvolver as altas porque ela pensa
como ela pensa e quando ela faz isso ela
começa a ver caramba
não faz sentido nenhum a crise que eu
tenho não faz sentido nenhum
mas ela nunca parou para examinar isso
então gosto de perguntar isso
perguntar qual é o centro da questão pra
você porque você disse tal coisa porque
você fez tal coisa pergunta simples você
faz escuta próximo ponto é
superimportante pessoal linguagem
importa uma mesma palavra pode ter um
significado completamente diferente pra
mim do que tem para outra pessoa
no nosso estudo a gente viu que quando a
gente faz uma mesma pergunta sem usar as
palavras gênero o feminismo por exemplo
a quantidade de pessoas que responde de
maneira favorável por de 40 4% para 75
por cento
eu não estou dizendo para invisibilizar
palavras que têm uma carga política ou
histórica super relevantes o que estou
dizendo aqui é a gente pode escolher com
abordagem ter como receber com
sensibilidade em cada momento dependendo
de quem é a pessoa à nossa frente
linguagem importa muito com a gente quer
furar a bolha construir pontes
vamos fazer isso com cuidado que a gente
quer que outra pessoa tenha com a gente
também
então diante isso aqui é super simples
salva-vidas já salvou minha vida já me
salvou de drs que pareciam impossíveis
rebobinar a fita o nome que eu aprendi
com a amiga muito querida chamada carol
na lom e assim se a pessoa que disse
alguma coisa você checa
se você entendeu repetindo pra ela peraí
estamos dizendo que x mais y é igual à z
quando você faz isso dá uma chance da
outra pessoa interpretasse o que ela
tentou dizer chegou em você mesmo
então ao invés da conversa ficar super
ténéré anda ela fica mais alinhada
porque vocês vão estar falando da mesma
coisa isso salva vidas pessoal no
trabalho em casa com a família
o teste tem se vocês não lembrarem de
mais nada teste isso aqui é muito bom
respirem uma conversa tensa a gente vai
esperando - vai entrando menos oxigênio
na nossa cabeça a gente quer o tenso
fechado travado quando eu respiro relaxo
eu convido a outra pessoa relaxar junto
com a gente
junto comigo eu dou chance dela pensaram
que ela está dizendo eu ganha outra
chance de pensar melhor
estou dizendo isso facilita fazer todo o
resto
facilita dizer não sei
a pessoa fala uma coisa que não conhece
ao invés de rebater ciro disse eu não
sei eu não conheço isso não conheço esse
dado não com esse conceito explica e
conta mais
onde é que você aprendeu isso com que
você aprendeu isso porque isso vai estar
junto com a pessoa uma parceria
você não tá no cabo de guerra você está
de novo construindo pontes e não
querendo vencer o outro
quando você vai fazendo essas coisas
facilita muito encerrar uma conversa
mantendo a porta aberta
você vai saber executar uma pausa quando
necessário
a pausa diz respeito a reconhecer quando
você não tá dando conta mais
às vezes a conversa ficou muito difícil
você pode simplesmente dizer não tá bom
pra mim e evitado eu tô desequilibrado a
gente pode seguir depois isso é um gesto
de carinho com outra pessoa e você pode
desenvolver uma parceria
você não precisa concordar com o outro
mas podem ter uma relação de longo prazo
um aprendendo com o outro um aprendendo
com a história de vida do outro
tudo isso pessoal esse monte de coisas
desemboca na minha grande aposta grande
aposta
a gente precisa de mais pessoas
construtores de pontes mais do que 15%
só da nossa população precisa se engajar
com isso construir pontes está disposto
a desenvolver mais equilíbrio emocional
mais empatia mais compaixão mais
generosidade mais fluidez no dia a dia
em todas as conversas
eu estou pedindo pra ninguém ficar tendo
conversas chatas e difíceis o tempo
inteiro
isso aqui é sobre ter melhores relações
em qualquer lugar onde você esteja a ter
mais liberdade e mais escolhas construir
pontes mesmo nas situações mais difíceis
e vocês não precisam confiar em mim
teste em experimentem o chamado e se
construam uma ponte hoje quem é uma
pessoa tem agora quem é uma pessoa que
vocês gostariam de ter uma conversa
difícil uma pessoa que pensa bastante
diferente de vocês e vocês não estão
tendo essa conversa
talvez uma relação que está morrendo uma
relação que você acha que já morreu
isso não precisa ser assim é só uma
pessoa com vida ela não bate papo liga
manda uma mensagem os as pernas vai até
ela
atentos ao que você lembrar disso daqui
se não lembrar de nada só chega e tem
essa conversa
se você quiser praticar ainda mais coisa
joga no google como conversar com quem
pensa muito diferente de nós você não vê
um estudo completo baixar um livro e um
documentário mas tudo isso é secundário
diante do que vocês podem sentir tanto
de frente para a outra pessoa e vendo
uma conexão que vocês achavam que era
impossível improvável acontecer bem na
sua frente
eu sinto isso toda semana tendo essas
conversas pessoal
talvez você sinta alegria que eu tenho
sentido sempre com esses diálogos o meu
convite é esse qual ponte
vocês vão construir hoje qual relação
vocês não vão deixar morrer
hoje recebi o convite
obrigado
[Aplausos]